here we go
[Music]
gonna be a cast where we talk about
stuff
and there's some stuff we can't talk
about
some stuff we can
[Music]
so that's uh that's the guitar i have
right now um
i'm in the process of getting uh a
proper acoustic guitar um
the uh one that you've seen in this
podcast many times
before um is actually like broken
and it always has been
it always has been always will be
yeah
um so i
have made the commitment to get uh not
it doesn't have to be super fancy you
know but just like a decent playing
guitar you know sam has that traveling
one that little taylor that i really
really like
but uh
i don't know if i need taylor yeah
jake you deserve the best
i'm going to get the best sneakers i'm
going to get off
i mean i'm going to get asleep an ivanez
is the best
i think once you hit 30 there's one
thing in life just save up some money
for and spend it on it's a good
instrument assuming yeah
if you've been playing up to this point
you still haven't stopped now's the time
to buy a nice one that's true i have
been playing instruments since i was
i've been playing guitar since i was 12
up to this point and i haven't really
stopped
uh and if you don't play an instrument
get an instrument when you're 30 because
your friends will think you're cool yeah
yeah yeah but don't don't get an
expensive one
i'll wait three years and then i'll
learn an instrument yeah yeah because
right now i have a smooth brain no
instrument knowledge right now what a
plan matt yeah that's a great plan yeah
it's the it's the midlife crisis plan
knowing an instrument takes takes the
wrinkles off your face and puts them in
your brain
wow
i don't even know what that means but it
sounds interesting it keeps you youthful
and makes you smarter oh okay okay there
you go you need to wrinkle your brain a
little bit more it sounds like
i clearly
get them brain wrinkles then clearly you
got that chrome brain dude
let me just make a goodbye guitar there
we go there's made
i'll do the same thing okay but you you
you have it
set it now yeah and then have like your
google calendar notify you
three years from now on
for my birthday in three years yeah
jake you should get one of those guitar
kits where you make your own guitar and
you should make a vlog about it i'm just
saying it's
it's it's okay i know you've got like
time
yeah that sounds really tough to do
hey you just follow the instructions
it's
it's a fine art making a good guitar
it's uh crap
it's gonna be good yeah yeah no one said
that oh it's a balance
but it'll be yours i'd rather just you
know how and you know how cheap you can
get like a decent guitar these days it's
pretty amazing go to a secondhand store
man secondhand music store well that too
i mean the old one was a yamaha that i
got for like a hundred bucks
um
and you know with a nice pair of strings
on there it actually sounded like
pretty good
um there's a noticeable difference when
you play like a a real guitar but yeah
you know
marginal
some of the best guitars i ever played
are like old worked guitars with super
high actions and you can barely press
the strings down but they sound
interesting that sounds like the wood
the wood in a guitar it like it actually
resonates
better the older it is it's like
you know a brand new guitar isn't going
to sound as nice especially in classical
guitars
like finally my yamaha my starter
student classical has mellowed out and
it's like the best sounding guitar now
it's crazy and it's like been 12 years
so i wonder if you can put him in like a
wine cellar and it'll
get in
it'll age faster i mean aren't the best
violins in the world the stradivarius
violins that were made in like the 1500s
or whatever dude and like people still
use them and play with them mm-hmm yeah
oh my god
that's too much for me dude i couldn't
handle that kind of pressure
look if you're like the best violinist
in the world go for it like isn't that
cool to like have this artifact and
still like have it that's amazing that's
so cool that's like the most cool dude i
got to go to the met over the weekend
when i was in new york and they have a
whole exhibit this whole room in their
permanent collection wait did you go to
the met gala with all the losers
celebrities
no i was there before all the losers
celebrities you were like all black like
the the
yeah i wore a garbage bag yeah
[ __ ] those people
anyways let's move on
nick you were at the met gala oh no i
mean
there were a bunch of stradivariuses in
case there was the first piano oh yeah
sorry not the first piano the oldest
piano
that is in existence still is there and
it's like one of the first pianos made
by the inventor of the piano
and there's no glass case around it
there's just this sign that says please
do not touch
right there asking they're just asking
for someone to freaking play that key
and i wanted to so badly
i didn't want to get kicked out because
i still wanted to see all the swords
you know the strings are wired up with
like vibration sensors maybe that's what
they should do they should put up a sign
that says please don't touch if you do
you will not be able to see the swords
all sword privilege is revoked it's like
they were they were like almost baiting
someone to touch this thing because they
also right below it have this freaking
video monitor with this guy just going
ham on this piano oh it's nice and it
sounds great and he's just having a
great old time he's like this is great
you should try it but don't touch it
you're like dang it i want to try it
i like the idea of being so good at
piano that you look at that piano like i
could give this a shot and if i play the
song well enough yeah they will won't
get mad at me i can see the swords
it's very daring
it's bold yeah yeah you'd have to really
be good though we don't want no scrubs
you know you're gonna if you're gonna
touch that piano you better do it you
better do it justice for this might be
the last song that ever comes out of it
so
you know
you gotta represent all of humanity's
musical ambitions oh god
oh
so much pressure
why do humans like music jake
uh you know i was i was thinking about
this the other day because i've got a
one-year-old daughter and she was
listening to a song and she was dancing
that's adorable and it's like
it's not like she knows it's not like
she yeah
it's not like she's like oh yeah people
dance and dancing is cool so i'm gonna
dance too yeah you know like she just
hears it and she starts dancing
it's like an innate behavior that humans
have to yeah like yeah move their bodies
to a rhythm right well i think it's i
mean i think it's not that much
different than like you know
um
an actual physical form of interacting
with something because it creates a
physical sound wave
the physical sound wave happens in a
pattern
that
your brain recognizes as like harmonious
or consistent you know um it's got a
it's got a mathematical pattern to it
and then i think you know it's it's
almost like
yeah it's like a physical response that
i think goes deeper than i mean
animals dance you know monkeys dance
like there's all kinds of
birds do little dances to each other all
the time and clicks and like make little
i think it's just something that goes
deeper than
than humanity for sure yeah yeah i mean
like you have like you know beating
hearts and like the rhythm of walking
like left right left right
you have
you know you have melodic inflections in
how we speak to each other so
but like imagine when you're in water
you know like when you're in water you
immediately you immediately do this
yeah you start you know i don't know if
that's learned or if that's natural but
like
you immediately try to swim and babies
will do this too if you put a baby in
water they'll immediately try to swim i
think it's kind of the same like if you
it's
you hear music and you're immediately
like trying to connect with it and like
understand the beat and like once you
you know if you have it and it makes
sense to you then all of a sudden you
start bobbing your head and tapping your
feet
it's just strange how we have we can
pair music so well with emotional tones
yeah like oh yeah you know it's weird
that those two pair like you know i
could see like oh we enjoy music we
enjoy rhythms you know like it it
triggers the things that you know in our
brain that are wired up to make us walk
or you know appreciate heartbeats or
like all those other instinctual things
but then it's like oh and we can also
define various emotional tones with it
and that's like that's weird i don't
know if that's natural or if that's
learned i was about to say that's
probably a learn thing because you have
to connect them you have to connect like
mute certain types of music to emotions
right so yeah
yeah i wonder you're listen
in like another dimension there's like
kids videos are those
gas pipe sounds that they use in horror
movies
that's what we learned that represents
like innocent happiness
[Laughter]
i'm gonna cry it's so touching
give me that xylophone to represent my
inner darkness yeah yeah
really brooding the happy the happy like
caribbean xylophone
dude so emo um
yeah there's probably another dimension
where that's going on right now
at least maybe a podcast similar to this
yeah and they start out that podcast
with a very interesting song yep
everyone just screams
at the top of their lungs
and then they talk about it for 12
minutes before they actually get into
the topic of what this podcast is
the music is the most important thing in
humanity right seriously let's get on
track gentlemen
okay you guys went out and shot a video
yesterday what happened what the hell
happened out there oh man well i barely
made it out alive it was crazy yeah no
i'm kidding niko this came up quick
because when we discussed this topic
originally it was kind of chill you know
christian and i were talking about this
today and it was like hey um
we'll have a couple sword fighters come
into the studio and you know
just film like a cool like you know
what would a fight scene actually look
like type yeah
and then all of a sudden
christian christian was sending me uh
memes
last friday
about how things escalated quickly
yeah well if you guys don't know by now
now you know how i operate
when it comes to sword fights that's
that's actually been the last two
lightsaber style videos yeah i guess all
the videos i make are lightsaber videos
now even though i said i'd never go back
to them when i was like 10 years old i
make lightsaber videos
on youtube we're lightsaber people
uh
yeah well you know so
we're making we we do all these stuntman
react videos where we critique
stunts and we talk about you know not
necessarily rigging on them for not
being real because you know there's a
difference between like movie reality
and reality reality but we've talked
about wouldn't it be cool if
somebody took the time to portray
something like a sword fight
using authentic choreography and
authentic sword strategy and it wasn't
just purely acrobatics and like baton
swinging
uh
and so i mean
i've done some you know studies of the
blade
studies of the blade and so that's
something that you know i'm like that'd
be cool to see i would enjoy doing that
and we happen to have a pretty solid you
know network of people around us that
are very talented at those kind of
things as well
uh so
we decided you know let's let's take a
look at lightsabers let's take it beyond
the sword and not just lightsabers but
energy swords in general and like
what would an imaginary weapon like that
look like if we applied that realism
treatment because really you can go on
youtube and you can watch realistic
sword fights you know there's a lot of
sparring there's a lot of martial arts
up there but there's not a lot of like
hey let's take these people who are very
smart and talented and then have them
focus all their efforts on something
completely imaginary
and then just make it up
um that's what we did with these with
these lightsabers and
uh you know it was interesting seeing
the choreography come together because
it's it's something that's fresh and
it's new you know it's not like jedi
fighting like you see in star wars it's
you know like one there's so many
different
thoughts that have to go into moves when
you actually need to make them
strategic and sensible but a byproduct
of that is that moves carry more emotion
and intention which is like those are
like the key things behind like acting
and characters you know you need to know
what they want they need to be actively
trying to do that
and the moment in a sword fight that you
start like twirling your sword around
and spinning around the character no
longer apparently wants to kill the
other person
and apparently they'd rather dance
but you know whatever it's instinctual
right all that screeching in the
background just can't help yourself
in that alternate dimension
so what are like the key differences
between like a star wars branded
lightsaber duel star wars brain device
uh well
keith one key difference is
when you when you swing a sword
well so
luke lafontaine helped us choreograph
choreograph this and he's really good at
these kind of things and
he also usually very has a very deep
knowledge base and we'll just
share with you uh until you're like
unsolicitedly
it cares a lot
it's great i love it it makes it really
easy to film corner
for sure
because you will always get what you
need from him
lafontaine once said to me jake you know
you know what can you imagine where i'd
be if i had your face come on
oh yeah national treasure
um
so he choreographed the sword fight and
you know he's talking about you know in
real sword fights there's only just two
things you got to be good at it's
distance and time you have to be at the
right distance at the right time and as
long as you are out of distance the
other person can swing the circle
however they want they'll never hit you
and you know you literally have up to
like a quarter of an inch that you can
get into and if you're good enough
that's how you can position yourself but
likewise if you want to step into range
and hit somebody else
you are putting yourself in danger so
you have to time it just perfectly for
the for the amount of time that you are
in distance where they can strike you
and where you can strike them they do
not have the time to be able to hit you
and you have the time to be able to hit
them oddly enough this all applies to
smash brothers as well
you'll watch for you like an opponent's
sword
you know if they're going to go for a
strike you know they lift it up and they
start to bring it in for a strike you
know so there's a certain amount of time
it takes the sword to travel they lift
the sword too far out of center now it
has to travel that entire distance to
get to you and if your sword is in
center or in a you know closer position
to hit them well as long as you move
fast enough and your distance is good
you it'll take you less time to hit them
and you'll get the strike and in a lot
of sword fights you're just going for
wrists you're not going for like body
strikes you're not going for
decapitations or giant you know cleaves
you're just going for the wrists and if
you can hit the wrists you win
and so that's one of the things that was
i was gonna say programmed that's one of
the things that was choreographed into
the swordfight was
very conscious wrist strikes and
distance maneuvers and an attempt to
just control the center with your sword
and then go for the other opponent's
arms which is not big and flashy but if
you can see it clearly and it can kind
of be highlighted suddenly you know once
again it's oh all i need to do is hit
the other character's wrist look how
close this is look how close it is to
life and death look how close this is to
one winning and one losing uh and so
that was like that's something that's
interesting to see come out of it
another thing is
you know when when making an attack you
need to be
also defensively attacking so to speak
so
if your attack does not land or you miss
you can't then then just leave yourself
open for a counter attack you know your
sword needs to land controlled in the
center you know keeping the opponent at
range or boxing out their blade wherever
it might be
and once again this this can really
limit the amount of acrobatics and
spinning you can do with the blade
but as long as you can communicate that
intention of of these sorts of deadline
these swords are dangerous you are you
are in a good position
you know one of the things that like
a lot of this applies to gun fights too
and this is one of the things that like
sam and i
talked a lot about when we were working
on lifeline because there's a couple gun
fights in that and you know we do all
different types of gun fights right
there's tactical reloads where
really
guns might as well be shooting
you know thank you cards for all the
damage they do um
but then you have uh you know more
serious stuff and when we were like
working on lifeline we talked about how
you know we try to communicate this to
the actors and the rest of the crew on
set is that whenever the trigger of a
gun is pulled
in real life
you know if you're not at the shooting
range but if you're actually like you
know in a fight it's with the intent of
killing somebody every time that
triggers pulled you don't just go blah
blah blah casually it's
you know each one of those moments has a
lot of weight behind it and if you just
write a script like the character shoots
a couple times he runs on the hall and
shoots a couple more times they shoot
back and they duck and they shoot some
more like you're making each one of
those life and death decisions just they
flippant like whatever you know i'll
just shoot some bullets down the hallway
you know i'm going to take cover oh
shoot some more bullets over the thing
it's like no like
each one of those could kill a person
and not just the person you're shooting
at but somebody else behind the wall
that the boat's going to go through
and
you know trying to portray a gunfight
with that that uh that weight is tricky
but can be rewarding and then the sword
fight is very similar where every swing
is an intent to kill and also putting
your life on the line even more so
because in sword fights you have to put
yourself in range to land that swing so
every single moment you step into there
your adrenaline is spiked and your heart
beats breeding faster and you know the
the very inches of where your feet land
and how much footwork you have like all
that stuff matters a hundred percent
anyways there's a longer so so how do
you film so how do you frame how do you
film that how do you frame that though
you chill out and you back up
you don't get in there and do the jason
bourne you know you don't you don't did
jason born it no and you know like or is
it for as easy of a target as jason
bourne is it's really just like a couple
fight scenes in one of the bourne movies
like a lot of the other born fight
scenes are shaky cam but they're
actually super fun and really well shot
and you can actually follow them it's
just
they are done in a way to be chaotic and
to be thrilling but they i think they
actually a lot of them do succeed in
doing that but in this case
you know like in a jason bourne fight
you're not
necessarily there to see the technique
at the end of the day they're throwing
punches and doing some judo grapples and
you've probably seen that fight about 10
times before it's happened in jason
bourne so you know when the fight
happens in jason bourne the choreography
itself while
good and fun
is not necessarily worth highlighting
over
the characters in the cinematography and
the emotion of the scenes like all the
stuff is probably more important than
like well check out this cool way he
blocks a punch pretty neat huh like
there's not a whole lot of that in those
movies but when you get into a fight
where you're trying to be very realistic
with the fight then you do need to do
that you need to show wow check out this
cool way they block the punch check out
this cool way he goes for an attack and
almost gets cut but has a clever way out
of it like all those little moves and
decisions are a lot more important
and if you do the shaky cam thing and
you get in there you're not going to see
any of that so
when we shot this fight scene
we also approach it with a very
different like
cinematic approach of you know we do a
lot of handheld fight scenes on on
corridor but in this case it was very
smooth
very like stabilized cinematic like we
kept referencing like dune and like
blade runner 2049 as our i guess just
roger deakins as our
yeah we just we just referenced roger
deakins for all our cinematographers it
was easy
but specifically so he could you know
make pretty wide angles and have nicely
framed side shots show all the swords
and honestly
you know luke was watching all this and
he's you know it does design and
choreography and coordination all that
kind of stuff
so he comes up with cool angles too for
like his his job but he's just saying
like just back it up and make sure you
get it all in frame just back it up make
sure you get all the frame that's a
great shot you didn't quite get it all
in frame make sure you just back up and
get it all in frame and like that was
his only notes like for the entire day
was just back it up get it all in frame
i mean i mean i would i'd play the line
you know i want to be just close enough
that it's exciting still but
yeah that was uh
it does take a lot of the work off of
your shoulders
when the stuntmen are good
and the
choreography is good and tells a story
which it did in this case you're just at
that point you're feeling a dance back
it up
keep it on the frame yeah
yeah yeah yeah and i just saw an edit
that nico made uh until one in the
morning last night yeah so we shot for
10 hours and i got hey started putting
the footage i got home mate dinner is
like oh i really want to see the footage
and i sat down like this is cool i
should cut a few shots together and then
like it was 1am i'm like okay i need to
go to bed
he walks in and you're like itching your
neck going just one more
just a little bit more
yeah pretty much just one more i paid
for it a little bit this morning that
and you know holding a camera in my
hands for 10 hours straight yesterday so
yeah
okay that's it i've done it uh as
promised over the last few weeks i've
spent my entire life just reading
through all these books looking for any
hint any word any paragraph that could
tell people where they can go for all of
their stock asset needs for creators and
businesses alike turns out i've read
through all these books and there's
nothing and that's why courtesy of
today's sponsor storyblocks i'm just so
thankful that there is a place where
people can go to get stock assets i'm
just over the moon about it so here's
the deal you can go to storyblocks and
you can get high quality 4k b-roll you
can get images you can get music you can
get after effects templates motion
graphics and more and they have a
virtually unlimited library that they're
constantly updating so every time you go
on there nothing is the same unlike
these books every time look every time i
go to page 52 in this book
turns out same words on there same
images
get out of here you know what i'm saying
thank god there is a place where people
can go to get royalty-free stock assets
to use in whatever they want however
they want through an unlimited
all-access plan thank god storyblocks
has that available just for you and hey
if you're part of a creative team
consider talking to your team lead about
an enterprise plan that's going to allow
you and the rest of your team to get all
the benefits of storybox it's something
we use here at quarter digital helps us
out a lot it improves smooths out and
enhances our production process saves us
a bunch of time saves us a bunch of
money and i gotta say it's real good
that it does that because the amount of
time it took me to read through all
these books
man probably a huge waste of money for
me to do that so anyways if you guys are
interested in getting started with
storybox for yourself consider clicking
the link in the description below or
heading over to storyblocks.comcast
and next time here's what i'm gonna do i
found a bunch of old vhs tapes okay in
my studio i'm gonna watch through all of
them okay i will let you know in another
week or two if there's anything on these
vhs tapes that can tell you where to go
for all of your stock asset needs in the
meantime have fun uh enjoy story blocks
and now back to the podcast
yeah it seemed like in the edit like and
this is definitely true from when we
were shooting it in the coverage it was
a lot of wide a lot of like showing the
action and then when we do cut in for
the close-ups that's for the emotional
moments yep you know that's not showing
the action necessarily or the technique
it's about like the emotional beats and
how that impacts the story yeah which is
like it can be almost like so vanilla in
a sense that
you can almost feel like you should be
discouraged from doing that as a
filmmaker it's like oh show the fights
in a wide then cut to a close-up to show
the emotions it's like that's that's
like babies first editing techniques
but then again the third technique is
you make one of them a dutch angle
yeah but like also like you know if you
look like a dialogue scene in a really
good movie there's still it's baby's
first dialogue scene yeah over the
shoulder telephoto shot with the person
lit nicely from one side and an edge
light it's like they're not reinventing
the wheel it's the dialogue and the
acting that really is what you're trying
to showcase and
same thing with the swordfight you know
like you're saying that like you pull it
back and you simplify the cinematography
because really you're just there to
showcase the actors doing their thing
and doing their performance and the
writing in this case is physical body
language
yeah yeah and in this case i don't think
it is like baby's first you know editing
techniques and storytelling techniques
because people don't do it as much it's
true it's grandpa's first
grandpa thank you yeah grandpa learned
he's doing it
[Laughter]
yeah grandpa's finally crafted editing
i think we should talk briefly about how
cool the lightsabers are
i want to hear about i want to hear
about this ability too i want to hear
about the facility i want to hear about
brett
broughton
he's the star of the show
was was brett like the wise
old man was i should look at the
definition of this real quick
brett was like on the script he's
referred to as the technician but i
don't that's not quite what he actually
is he is a
uh
hold on i gotta define
who played the sage
the stage we don't know yet brett was
the proctor he was the proctor the
proctor so there's the story of this of
this short film this cinematic short
masterpiece uh this
short film the short sword fight
is that it's not star wars it's just
generic future um and
this is a sword fighting school where
they learn how to fight with energy
blades because i want to stay away from
like jedi stuff right i don't have the
force to get involved in this gotta you
know get the fight scene's not gonna
look like a star wars fight scene so
let's not make it star wars um
so this is a sword fighting school that
produces the best students in the world
and they have a certain method of doing
that and that is in order to graduate
the student must fight their teacher in
a duel to the death because it's one
thing to have training it's another
thing to actually have to deal with your
adrenaline your nerves and getting into
a situation that's actually life or
death which if you got into a real sword
fight that's what it more or less would
be
so
they get into a sword fight and uh brett
is the proctor watching all this happen
uh meanwhile on the edge of the scene
there's a janitor who's kind of like you
know just taking out the garbage and
mopping the floors and they just stop
and they watch because this is
fascinating
um
this old man like steps up next to them
and starts explaining kind of what's
happening you know this is graduation
day basically gives them the setup i
just gave gave you here and also kind of
breaks down the fight a little bit what
the fighters are thinking and this is
kind of my way of just getting to show
the audience and highlight some of the
things that are happening in the fight
in a way that's in the world of this
piece but needless to say halfway
through the student gets his butt kicked
and gets killed
because his teacher is better than him
um you know and the student has some
flaws in his technique but because it's
the future brett driver here the son the
proctor walks out and pulls out this
giant machine
and brings it back around and uses it to
reattach the limbs and seal up the holes
on this dead student
of life son the son of love right
because this the reason this school is
the best school for sword fighters in
the world is because they can actually
do fights to the death and then revive
the students so they can keep going and
learn from their mistakes so when they
go out in that world and they don't have
access to the giant machines because
they're not in the school's facilities
anymore they at least have you know a
handle on their nerves and have figured
out you know they can control their
adrenaline and their mental state and
all that kind of stuff so we watch as
the fight goes through a few more
iterations of the student trying
different techniques and we actually hit
on some tropes of different sword fights
like he does the star wars you know
flipty do whoopty do stuff and gets
killed he does like the super emotional
big hits that you see in like you know
john wick he gets killed um
he does you know uh
another style like style movie sword
fighting and then just sort of gets
twisted out of his arms and then just
literally chops off both his hands in
like a helicopter motion uh and then
eventually you know the student learns
from his mistakes he centers himself
learns to control both his technique his
head space all kind of stuff and of
course okay well i won't spoil the
ending but yeah don't spoil what happens
hey so what what happens if they like
can't bring you back though you know
well then you die and that's why they're
you're still nervous
do you sign that waiver when you accept
like that those things
because last semester timmy didn't come
back
exactly it's high stakes this is high
stakes high school
okay
yeah so that's that's a general premise
for this but
it's fun to be able to because that's
the other thing it's like in a real
sword fight once again
they don't last that long so it's like
you know pop pop pop pop pop
then
i got cut it's over uh so this is a way
for us to be able to do that and then be
able to get back into the fight just you
know
it's cool the effects like you know arm
reattaches and the kid gets back up and
back into the fight and you go for it so
yeah
so
okay
so did you shoot everything yesterday or
was there is there another way we didn't
we didn't shoot the dialogue stuff yet
okay so we just shot the fight scene we
did shoot at this really cool warehouse
yeah yeah it was awesome christian how
did you find this this place
scrounging scrounging along
so we use pure space a lot for our
location hunting and uh locations in los
angeles are expensive
uh you're probably looking at a minimum
of like three thousand dollars just to
get an open space
uh and then if you want to like look
nice it's like another thousand dollars
and that's a lot of money
especially for a day of shooting
uh you know obviously like there's big
productions that have the budget so
you're kind of
you don't really have any anybody going
like ah man fine i'll cut you a deal
because they can just not cut you a deal
and have a big budget thing come in
instead dude when we filmed sync back in
the day
we made a budget and we were like yeah
20 000 for locations that should be
that should be plenty
yeah was it
no
locations were cheaper back then though
i remember uh well
there was a few that we pretty much blew
through that in like two days of filming
on
um yeah there was that
medical facility
in
santa clarita it was five thousand
dollars i remember that and then there
was that bank vault where they filmed
the dark knight yeah
and then there was that
futuristic office
right in uh skid row she's literally in
the middle skid row yeah anyways
and all the rest it was like backyards
of our friend's place and like guerrilla
stuff on the street
richard ryan's apartment richard ryan's
apartment yep remember that he was
really chill on him to let us shoot in
his apartment
it helped that he was the building
manager
yeah he did help yeah
yeah that way no one could kick us out
yeah except for the landlord
yeah the landlord and the the permit
police
permit pd
permapd yeah it was really funny
yesterday morning when i walked on to
the location i talked to the the manager
on location and she asked us if we
wanted to back in our trucks and our
sprinter vans i was like
we have a kia soul
we do we got some cars just our cars
i mean i have two sandbags in that glass
yeah think of how legit it would be
though guys if we backed in a sprinter
van
think of how legit that would be it'd be
pretty pretty legit it would be pretty
legit nico this marks i'm marking this
one down on the we should have bought
that bus jake was this all was this
podcast just a ruse for us everything's
been around now yeah he planned the
record now he's saying okay here jake i
was reading we said we weren't gonna
present him with the powerpoint yet
9 15
20 21.
dude we can use the van for other things
we can have it be like an office
lightsaber
[Laughter]
well actually you guys know
i might be convinced
like i know we're talking are we talking
stakeouts we're sitting in like the
driver's seat your seat lean back
and then there's one guy in the front
who like is just the driver but he sits
there you know
he's like a boss
you know and then yeah and then it's
like and then boss is in the back with
the technician
and then
technician pulls up the exterior cameras
right just an unnecessary amount of
screens yes
you should always put people's lav mics
on in the sprinter van like we're giving
them a wire yeah yeah then send them
into the set and then it says
it says like billy's typewriter repair
yeah
billy's mobile typewriter repair
yeah for when it doesn't remember their
phrase is like for when it just doesn't
click
he's warming up dude you're prepped man
where'd that come from this is actually
part of the did you see what we're doing
yeah you guys burned this didn't i do
i've been ready for this
forever
we've got multiple design options okay
we've got billy's typewriters
we have uh we have the dueling wizard
design it's gonna be a little bit more
expensive for the dueling wizards but
you know i think if we can get sam on
board then it's good yeah how can you
get how can you elevate it though it's
like i've seen dueling wizards how do
you how do you get some spice
like some more spice than than more
airbrushed dueling wizards yeah when we
do
candy paint you know like sparkle
sparkle paint yeah yeah and then maybe
uh
maybe instead of a sliding door it's got
suicide doors
oh oh oh
wings yeah the goal wings
no no suicide doors open
gold oh right right right
not the ones that open like that not the
x-wings the the suicide doors that open
backwards
right so you can open it like suicide
stores doors suicide stories
because you're more likely to die with
those doors
but i don't know why that would be
suicide accidental death doors for sure
if you jump out of a moving car you're
going to die
yeah
yeah it wouldn't even be homicide at
that point because that's killing of a
human being by a human being
i i don't know are they corridors
darwinian doors
anyway because it's cool nico that's why
how much is a sprinter van jake i mean
how many miles does it have
100k 100 100k
oh god uh how old is it it doesn't need
to be nice i mean it can how old is it
how old is it i don't know it's probably
four years old three or four four years
old he's got a hundred thousand miles so
it's driven a lot
uh probably
probably thirteen
thirteen thousand fourteen thousand not
in this market they made probably more
now yeah it's probably more than like 18
of that well by the time this podcast
goes live it'll probably be like 19.
jesus i had to buy a new car and it's
like 10 grand more than they're actually
worth that sucks but you got to do what
you got to do you know so even even the
new car market is inflated yeah it's not
as bad which is why i went new but still
oh man yeah it's still rough yeah
well you know you dump 5.6 t into the
economy and it has a tendency to do
strange things that's about how much we
spend on the global war on terror when
you don't count the medical bills after
the fact but anyways i digress
sprinter vans have gotten expensive and
the candy paint job is really what this
all comes down to that's going to add
value though it's going to add value
and we can film with it and the problem
is that it doesn't make if you go that
route you don't have a very good
stakeout van because now it's like super
noticeable
you know
so that's there's a problem with that
yeah
but maybe you take it to high-end like
events and now you have a stakeout van
at the high-end event because they
wouldn't let in billy's typewriter
repair exactly but now they're like okay
that's how we get in the main gala next
year that's how we get into that gala
yes we can we can it can be like an
exterminator van and we'll all dress as
bugs yes
inflatable bubbles to them
and just roll down the stairs i don't
know what you're referring to but
remember those incredible bubbles that
we ran over carmichael oh those okay
yeah yeah i uh we'll roll over just
we'll wear just those
just sexy suicide doors by the way okay
okay please all right that's what we've
all been waiting for all right sorry
this is from the website i have a
feeling that they're bullshitting me
they actually have no idea but i'm to
tell you what they said from the website
the little part of my brain that goes
and they're making it up
triggering here so
you said uh rear hinge doors these
suicide doors by the way suicide doors
started from the day of carriage design
where they wanted the doors of the
carriage to open like nice doors to a
house like a french mansion
um
so apparently uh back in the day before
seat belts um
the wind would blow your doors open
and you'd go flying out the car and the
subaru in 1969 had this problem
also if you are opening the door and it
gets hit by a car like i said you're
stepping on the street the door closes
back on you killing you as opposed to
getting knocked open away from you oh my
god
and that's about all i could find i
guess you know like i said i think this
website was
like they had some really like flimsy
arguments beyond that that felt like
they didn't do anything someone like
kill themselves like on purpose i think
it's because the opening thing i think
it's because of the opening thing the
way that they open
like yeah you can fall out
i think that's sort of so if you sit if
you sit suicidal with a suicide door
you're
suicidal
yeah
yeah yep well
that's uh good to know i'll put that one
in my pocket for later yeah and i don't
know
i don't know if they've done them oh i
guess they do them on the phantoms but
after the lincoln continental after the
mid 60s lincoln continental they kind of
got rid of them
yeah i think also they mentioned that
people have a tendency like bonk people
when they open the doors because they're
not looking behind the car but they're
like it's probably not an issue because
the chauffeur is usually opening it for
you that's right that's right yeah the
carriage master yeah hey is that where
car comes from i've debated this for
years yeah does it come from a carriage
oh i've never thought about that that's
like probably a true question well i
have the internet here on my phone so
okay yeah can you look this up it does
welcome to the corner cast guys for the
rest of the night we're just going to
look up random things google [ __ ] do you
get wifi in that thing yeah
car comes from
latin
karum carus
old northern french car
which goes to car wheeled vehicle so
carriage yeah they come from the same
route okay so car
karum carus
et cetera i guess
it's always been a car since before the
car before the internal combustion since
before the car it was what about cab how
does cab like caboose and cab
is that just a place where passengers go
cabbie question
cabin
oh also
did you say there's no nick isn't there
no hard c in latin uh isn't it sar
that is no i think it's there's no heart
or soft s i'm pretty sure like that's c
sorry
oh you're right caesar was more like
kaiser is how that's all right kaiser is
how they'd pronounce it there's another
old old car word chariot
oh cherry
that's probably the first one yeah
so s's are pronounced like z's or
uh what is
if anyone's listening as a latin expert
right now please let us know sorry um
apologize yeah we've responded for this
yeah
yeah i don't know latin is crazy watch
barbarians you'll hear some real no
pronouns how do they do it
how do they do it did i pronounce this
how does that work
[Laughter]
how do you go from not having pronouns
to having pronouns
how does that work
slang probably it's got like yeah how
else does it work because it just became
easier to say yeah
because
because of the way you conjugated the
verb which is still the same in latin
dialect languages
i'm sure another language melded with it
to get there
did any guys look at the new iphone 13
stuff
um i saw like a cinematic reel which is
freaking sweet yeah so when the iphone
12 came out i saw i remember talking
maybe even on this podcast when it was a
futurology podcast which is just
becoming a futurology podcast again
right now
welcome back welcome back so i talked
about how
with uh with like the z depth of the
lidar on the iphone i feel like apple's
on their way to making large format
sensors not necessarily obsolete but way
more specialty uh
because they're basically getting it to
where it doesn't matter how big your
sensor is you can do all your depth of
field after the fact as long as you have
good like z depth and if you have a
lidar scanning the scene and then you
probably give a little ai sauce on top
so it can kind of fill in the details
uh you know you're probably looking at
you know the ability to actually judge
distance on all the pixels and then blur
them appropriately so that's what they
did
they're doing that they're doing that
post now they're doing that post in the
iphone 13 and it has the ability to do
uh focus pulling basically uh after the
fact because it's just it's saving a z
depth map of the scene when i say dz
death i mean a depth matte and then
that's combined in some ai stuff like
that does portrait mode on the phone um
but now i can do it in video in real
time and they have prores even oh sure
really which this is all really cool and
you know hey good job apple engineers
but maybe don't have a lightning port
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute there's usb 2.0 speeds
uh dude there's nothing worse than
trying to get a video file off of
yourself it's the worst it's the
absolutely it opens up eight folders
they're all named random numbers and
then your photos are randomly mixed in
all the photos everywhere it's like
there's no rhyme or reason
it doesn't mount either it's like yeah
so you guys can't get that you guys
can't like it it's like a purposely like
[ __ ] you from apple like don't open the
phone don't get your files we're going
to try to make it hard
that's those are the things i hate about
like modern
i guess like devices and games is like
there's a lot it's like we won't we know
you want this but also [ __ ] you a little
bit here can you just give me the thing
without the [ __ ] you yeah and it's like
no no no
how is there stock gonna be worth two
bill
dude
man they like making 30 on basically
every transaction on the internet is uh
how they get away with it
yeah
you know
i'm glad epic took him to court and i'm
sad to see people like oh sorry did i
say two bill i meant to trill yeah 2.4
trill
hey you know what they come to think of
it i think the american government kind
of needs that money maybe they should
liquidate
jake you've been listening to a lot of
talk radio no
no but
okay okay back in the day there was a
camera called the lg v10
that had manual focus pulling on it and
i'm trying to see yeah and i'm trying to
see if it was a post process or if it
was an actual camera it wasn't it had to
have been an act there's no way it was a
post process if it was like older than
one year that's like there's no way it
was supposed
unless there's a light field camera
which i doubt
but now with all the iphones like
leading up to this one the
the depth of field the fake depth of
field has been like kind of rough
because any fine detail like hair it
doesn't really work so it did you see if
that like it looks like it's it's it's a
little bit better but it looks like it's
definitely yeah it's like that edge on
the character's head is a little weird
yeah it's pretty clear you can clearly
tell it's a post-process thing still
it's got a little bit like that video
game okay yeah yeah
not quite there yet but yeah yeah i
almost bought one of the v10s because it
had that feature um
and i think it came out like five years
ago yeah about five years ago
manual focus it's saying
that was kind of one of the first ones
that had like
wait what you could pull focus on your
camera on your phone
[Music]
with your fingies
you don't need a lens
yeah okay camera tech is definitely like
going crazy places like we're definitely
at the point right now where it's like
you have zero excuses for your stuff not
to look cinematic outside just you
have not yet gained the knowledge on how
to make things look cinematic like we
got like technically speaking like you
can't blame it on your gear anymore it's
like literally
all the gear is good and it's not only
good it's like
paradigm shifting good
you know
man yeah it's pretty crazy i feel like
if you like to be a really good
cinematographer these days i feel like
you need to really have your head
wrapped around color grading and
lighting more than like anything else
and cinematic language like when to you
know do different moves and framings and
stuff like that
yeah and not rely on gimbals for
everything i know we just shot a gimbal
movie yeah but that's a different thing
but dude nothing pissed me off when this
guy just shoots everything on gimbal
he keeps it locked off and tries to be a
tripod but he's not and you see this
little sway side you're like dude
it's not a tripod it's not a tripod
did this happen in your edit nick in
your movie edit yes
[Music]
we didn't have time to like switch on
and off of the gimbal so like we had to
shoot a lot of things just kind of
rushed on the gimbal yeah the gimbal
look is so specific too you can always
tell with that like x and y yeah exactly
i'm happy we did for the movement shots
but like some of the shots that are like
the locked off shots are just like not
usable can you fix any of it with post
well we had a b camera on sticks so
luckily i'm using that a lot so we got a
good even ratio but like yeah i'm just
never gonna roll on a gimbal
ever again unless it's a very specific
shot how are things going with your
movie nick good yeah yeah so you shot
your movie back in the fall slash winter
you're the winner yeah which is i'm so
impressed that you managed to shoot a
feature film yeah um still going well
they always yeah
they take a while
so but yeah so like you're in the
editing stages now yes assembly first
cut second cut basically
yeah so
through
june
and july the editor was doing her
cut her first assembly cut
and got that and
had a little breakdown as you do yeah
because it's like yeah it's very uh
from what you want
yeah yeah and like especially on an
indie thing because like you're
scrounging for time and there's like
very specific things that happen on set
where you're like okay as long as we do
it this specific way
it's not in the script but we need to do
it this way and i can like fudge this
and make it work because you know as an
editor i think of as you do and you do
how to how to shoot for your edit yep so
none of that translates the editor
sitting through all the footage yeah you
know oh absolutely
so
yeah all of august basically every night
i go home and just edit with this editor
and we've we're doing it all remotely
through zoom and through facetime and
it's working so and we're done like we
just finished the last scene yesterday
congratulations man thanks man so it's
well not done but like i have now
an hour exactly like 90 minute film you
have an edit
yeah dude and it's like
it's like cool to see like oh yeah we
shot that scene though and that's what
happens now like i said it's like cool
okay it's a movie
but yeah so i'm really close to the
point of
soliciting feedback from oh that's
awesome so yeah you guys will see
something soon
send it to me it's a very broad question
but like what's your experience been
like directing a feature film
this is the this is basically a an indie
you guys kind of scrounge the budget
together it's basically you going just
you and the rest of the team just going
just making it happen yeah we were just
like
we uh foresaw that there would be a
deficit of content like narrative
content through kovid because there is
um and most of the stuff being made is
documentaries or really big budget or
just like hey we made this movie on zoom
like you know yeah and like it's and
that's like quickly losing its novelty i
think so yeah hopefully in the american
film market and then in uh in the
european film market we can sell this
thing so and you know we weren't trying
to the thing is thrillers and horror
movies
they sell really well yeah like
people always want that kind of content
because there's a weird
i think voyeuristic draw to it like
that's why serial killer things do so
well right but anyway
we decided to make one of those and
i think we accomplished it i mean it's
pretty cool it's pretty intense it's
like one intense scene after another but
i guess as a director my takeaway would
be
uh i think i've said this before less is
more in almost everything like don't try
to do too much
and
most of the directions i gave were just
like
do that but less like you know so
that i think is valuable though to know
like
yeah anyone you know stepping onto a set
you know intensity doesn't always mean
quality so
and it can be very jarring especially in
a feature film when like
you can build up to that intensity but
like
you need to like
take your time with things and like
build up slowly so
i don't know it's been a learning
experience man
i mean every single one yeah i uh
how close is it to your vision you know
what you saw in your head when you're
reading the script slash like starting
to shoot it i think pretty pretty close
man really yeah i mean when i i think we
managed to pull we we were able to
achieve like we didn't have to cut back
on any of the locations or like change
the script too much for like
those kind of
material constraints because covid was
actually kind of a blessing i mean it
was really annoying having to direct and
have everyone in masks and like
do all this the briefings and the
testing and the
the code safety officer on there
you know but
we got hello locations for really cheap
everyone wanted to work they were just
bored so they're like yo
i know my rate is really expensive but
like
give me this and i'll do it because i
just want to be on set like i want to do
something and like we got like some
really great locations that would have
normally been
hustling bustling businesses and they
let us shoot there for cheap and
yeah it played in our favor overall wow
so
i don't know man i feel like that's what
the best the best like filmmaking
happens in my opinion is when you are
capturing
not just like your story but like a
moment around you that lends itself and
flavors that story in a really unique
way whether it's like you said you know
locations for
for for cheap so to speak or things that
otherwise would be hustling and busting
or like if you're shooting out in like
nature and like you it rains one day
you're just like screw it let's shoot in
the rain and something like this scene
takes on a whole new life and
spontaneity because of it
yeah yeah man those things are beautiful
like those little things that you can't
plan for and just happen so yeah that's
the cool part about being in on an indie
thing is because
you kind of don't have a choice to have
that stuff happen it's like well if it
rains we don't have any other options
oh man so yeah it was it was cool in
that respect i got to i sat down last
week and showed the uh the cut with tent
music so i
i spotted with my
uh hopefully who's gonna be the guy
composing this
if we can raise the money and uh we've
picked out a bunch of temp music that we
like from other films and i i set i
edited that that into the the current
edit
um and showed the co-producers chris and
kika who also are the actors and chris
wrote it she came up with the story
um so it's like the three of us are kind
of the team here yeah and they were
getting very emotional watching it was
which was really cool to me to see i was
getting emotional because they were
getting to move like i was like damn
okay this is really cool like especially
because he wrote the bloody thing and
he's still like invested in it you know
and like
they're like obviously know exactly what
went into it but they could still like
view it from an outside perspective that
was cool so that was like a little bit
of
like it was like a success kid moment
that's really cool
yeah yeah that's awesome yeah such a
good feeling yeah
what was like what was like one of the
biggest takeaways or lessons that you
learned like as a director oh that going
into it you didn't really expect
to learn
oh boy um or they're like a lot
yeah
always take the lens cap off always take
the lenses
remember that yeah yeah i'm
trying to remember it's usually in your
back pocket
it's usually in sam's back [ __ ]
action
here's a lens cap on set just go and
talk to sam you know
[Laughter]
of plastic
um i think honestly like
what took me a while was and this might
just be me but it was like
just letting people do their jobs yeah
you know
because like i've always shot my own
stuff i've always like
you know shot directed and edited and
usually been doing the lighting and
usually been the screenwriter before
that
and that's how all of us kind of
function so
it was kind of weird at first to be like
what do you mean i just stand here and i
look at the screen
and then i look at the actor's
performance that's all i do
oh cool
so that took me a while to get used to
but like
it's like oh that's why that's done
that's why like you don't like just do
everything yourself even though it feels
really good to be like yeah i did
everything myself you know yeah it's uh
it was it was uh definitely
nice to learn that like
i don't know just the ability to like
step back and let people contribute
their own things and like everyone did
and it was great and
you know
something i knew but i hadn't really
like experienced from that position
before so
but yeah and then honestly just
tone it down
turn it down that's a big one like yeah
you know
just
yeah the worst is like when you like i
just need a moment of this character
looking at the other person yeah and you
go through it it's like i can't find a
single moment of the person just looking
at the other person yeah
do you remember when we were filming
that uh i won't name the particulars of
this but there was one there was one
scene where we were filming and we had
uh a guy that was playing the president
for something
and we needed him to save one oh yeah
line
one line
and he just
kept committing to it like it was
stagecraft
and
like it was the most dramatic
it was for a montage
and all we needed was the line of the
president of the united states saying
something like issue the order
something super simple like that and he
was like
issue the order
and they're like no just say issue the
order and he's like
issue the order
oh my god
we're like no
just say it like it's it's intense
you're the president of the united
states and you're giving an order to
somebody else to issue an order
and then the camera stops rolling you're
like all right how would you say it say
it right now i was like issue the order
you're like yes do that
so we had the guy we had the guy that
was playing his like
like one of his secretaries in his
cabinet
actually say the line
because he
like couldn't he just couldn't
dude so awkward didn't have to do that
in front of the actors oh man like no
they know they know exactly what's going
on
why couldn't he just say
the order
that's why you film the rehearsals
they're like okay let's just do a quick
warm-up let's walk through the lines can
you just read them please okay issue the
order okay
[Laughter]
yeah and that's where directing is
another thing i learned is like
you can kind of direct yourself into a
corner sometimes if you try to get to in
it yes then you'll really get an actor's
head and then they start feeling like
they're not doing a good job and actors
like god bless them but they're very
like you know focused on like how am i
looking and how am i sounding yeah and
if they feel like they're not doing well
they're letting everyone down then it's
like you can have a bad situation
luckily that didn't happen too much but
yeah it was uh it's not like you had
people that knew what they were doing
here yeah i think so and like luckily
the two main actors in it it's a very
small cast they knew the script like the
back of their hands so it wasn't like i
had to remind them of the lines or
anything
um
it was just
yeah
some of the supporting actors definitely
we had that
we had to get them there for sure but
that's it's a cool challenge man it's
really fun it's weird i always end up
over directing people too like because i
like to explain my idea behind what i'm
printed no no no no no
and don't like i also try to be like
try to allude to what i'm looking for
sometimes like metaphorically it's like
you know imagine you're out like you
know i don't know trying to get me like
like i want you to look like you're
having fun like imagine you just hit the
perfect way of surfing and there's like
oh
but almost universally like
i always reel it in at the end with
after you've gone through the scene
you've been a whole bunch of direction
and you're like i got it it's really all
just been rehearsal for it's the actual
take which is all right just give me a
special just do your thing you got a
good take just play with it have fun
just do what you want to do and i want
you to go you know make it feel
different than not what everything else
you filmed and suddenly get something
spontaneous you get something natural
they're having fun they're committed
they're not in their head anymore and
then you actually get your good take
right there yeah yeah
definitely it's a
that's always a fun
gamble
that's good because sometimes it's like
crazy but yeah i've used that one a
couple times from you oh yeah
there's a lot of techniques yeah the
special
you get some stuff with this special
it depends on it depends on especially
it depends on who it is if you have a
wacky character like who's just gonna do
something that's totally outside of the
context of the scene then you know your
specials night might not work but
depends
yeah yeah well that's the key in having
good acting
that's true they would know
ideally what the character wouldn't do
i always think back to sorry i didn't
mean to interrupt you
i always think back to when we were
filming rebel blades
and lawrence newman
playing one of the soldiers these guys
aren't actors they're just like war
recreation guys and these are the guys
that are like into playing the red coats
and
revolutionary war recreations which is
like it's such a specific like boy you
guys are like really nerding out hard
you know
55th regiment of foot nico yes that's
right they were good too they were great
they were like when you had them play
their characters that they larped all
the time you know it's like yeah they
were really good but
you know having specific reactions to
moments that's that's acting that's real
acting and that's not necessarily
something they practice and they
practice being in character and like
improving stuff it's like i need you to
you know you get shot here by an arrow
and
you react to it you know and like that's
one of the things where
so we're talking to lauren's like you
know you're going to do his thing and
the arrow's gonna go through his face
right he gets shot through the cheeks
with an arrow
and
you know your face gets stuck in an
expression of like whoa holy [ __ ]
combined with oh my god i just got shot
in arrow and
he's like okay
i think i'll try this
you know he kind of like works like i'm
gonna go work on it for a while he
literally goes and walks off on his own
he just practices making a facial
expression for a while and he comes back
and goes all right i was thinking i
could do this and he just goes
like that i'm like that's perfect he's
like okay cool and then he walks off
again and then he practices just
literally making that one expression
over and over about five minutes until
it's time to shoot the shot and he comes
and just
nails it on the first day
yes i love this like like no bs no
acting school no
you know i don't know therapeutic
emotional feeling stuff just pure
mechanical i'm going to move my muscles
yeah
the worst is when they go off for five
minutes and they come back and it's
terrible yeah
that's the overthinking
yeah
yeah oh man there's so many joey
triviati jokes happening
if you know your friends
references
yeah anyway
well what did we talk about is there
anything else we want to go over
ah
nah we covered it all
that's it this is everything
guys we covered it all we shot a video
we got
okay there's a two things i didn't want
to talk about that are coming out in
over the next few weeks one is ren's
solar panels video the other is son of a
dungeon so more on that on the podcast
as we move along here um but um
has been what like a six month or six
month six week production eight week
production
that's a big video that's a big video
all right yeah yeah matt you've been
in it yeah me and ryan have been working
pretty closely on that for the past
month or two
two months or two or um three or four
three four
something like that um yeah and it's uh
it's it's we're definitely making great
progress on it but um yeah it's it's
something that like is constantly being
iterated on as we're editing it and
working on it so it's like
oh this is like this is like and half of
this this video is now a completely
different thing um and it's just like
it's just constantly are you done
filming voiceover for it
oh yeah we did yeah we actually did
finish that runs working on getting the
cut in of that so hey look at that yeah
it's combining a little bit of work
check-ins here with the podcast that's
what it's like to everybody you've ever
wanted to work at quarter digital this
is what it's like just without you know
the money i'm just gonna call you and go
hey man uh so uh how's it going
i have one more thing to say um son of a
dungeon
should we should we tell people the
official date because we're planning to
tomorrow on
and so i feel like we should say it
anyway do it
all right two weeks
september 29th
son of a dungeon first episode
uh it's not just the first episode and
if you're subscribed to the site you get
episodes one and two that's right first
two episodes dropping on the site and
you know we gotta drop we gotta drop
that first episode on youtube to get
people knowing what they're missing you
know that's that whole thing
um and then we're gonna roll them out
weekly
thereafter
and our boy daniel
bless his heart he's gonna take a break
from
crew cuts episodes because my god the
kids produced over 90 of them wow
there's so many
he hasn't had a seasonal he hasn't had a
season break yet
so
hashtag make daniel stop working
[Laughter]
i aspire to have like daniel's
dedication like he really he keeps me on
the straight and narrow
so yeah so he's gonna take uh uh
there's gonna be a season one crew cuts
break and then season two is gonna start
as son of a dungeon comes to a close
hey if you're listening to this podcast
on youtube and you've made it this far
i would like you to leave some
appreciation oh assuming you're also a
website subscriber and you watch the
crew cuts there i would like you to
leave some appreciation for daniel in
the comments below tell us tell him a
favorite scene a favorite episode
guys
d in chat for daniel
yeah
i
it's about time i mean obviously there's
cool comments on the website but he
deserves like he deserves some love and
on youtube you know you get all this
exposure you get all these views and on
the website it's much more focused and
you know it's amazing people who
subscribe on the website and really
enjoy our stuff but
we need to show them a little bit about
youtube youtube love too so shout out to
daniel
yeah get it let's get it all right
thanks for joining everybody until next
time
uh
oh we're gonna do a premiere when son of
a dungeon episode one comes out we're
gonna do a youtube premiere slash
website premiere slash recorded live
podcast where we react to people's
comments talk about the scenes it's
coming out it's happening
september 29th so
adios amigos and
c'est la vie and
i don't know what else to say but we'll
see you on the next one
[Music]
[Laughter]
now we're done now we're cut